je me suis engagé en politique
ah c'est au début des années 70 c'est
mon engagement militant a commencé avec
la campagne présidentielle de 1974 et
l'élection de valéry giscard d'estaing
à cette époque là j'avais 23 ans j'avais
18 ans j'ai vu une émission politique
locale où justement une jeune fille
monter une liste pour les municipales
et puis je me suis bâtie en oui moi j'ai
envie
j'ai eus an
de de m'engager pour ma commune je me
suis dit et pourquoi pas je me
présenterai pas aux prochaines élections
municipales
j'ai répondu à l'appel de françois
bayrou il voulait vraiment donner du
poids et de l'engagement à des femmes et
donc j'ai accepté puis j'ai accepté ça
comme d'engagements supplémentaires dans
ma vie c'est une rencontre avec le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui a déclenché mon envie d'oser
faire ce que lui d'ailleurs osé faire
quant à emmanuel parot le 28 janvier
2017 a fait un appel aux femmes en dix
ans les femmes
si vous ne commettez pas aux élections
législatives l'assemblée nationale ne
changera jamais visage il y avait plus
de femmes en politique donc en 2014 je
me suis engagé pour un mouvement un peu
citoyen que j'étais très petit vraiment
très petit j'étais déjà révoltés par le
fait de congés et du papier etc on le
recycle pas donc j'ai écrit à 7 en amont
mère je venais d'apprendre à écrire pour
lui demander instamment d'avoir de
bénéficier à notre tour d'un bac de
collecte pour recycler le papier et
quelques années plus tard je devais
avoir 12 ans il m'a écrit pour me dire
que ça y est ça avait enfin été
installés j'étais très content puisque
j'avais 12 ans et j'avais l'impression
d'avoir changé le monde me suis engagé
la première fois véritablement pour les
élections législatives donc c'était en
2017 suite à la à la mort de mon père
j'ai réalisé finalement à quel point la
vie était courte à quel point il fallait
vivre ses rêves et prendre ce risque
au cours de mes différents engagements
j'ai eu l'opportunité de visiter
certains lieux toutes ces rencontres
tous ces lieux m'ont fait comprendre
qu'il était important de défendre des
convictions des valeurs des princes
notamment la paix c'est en 2014 je crois
je suis passé devant les colonnades de
l'assemblée nationale et j'avais déjà en
moi cette envie de m'engager et devant
les colonnades je me suis dit là
sandrine tu peux faire bouger les choses
il ya des choses à faire pour les femmes
et des fausses choses à faire aussi pour
pour les français et pour voir aller
plus loin ensuite notamment en devenant
maman j'ai voulu poursuivre
cet engagement maintenant il se fait
aussi dans le cargo petit c'est plus
compliqué pour une femme de s'engager
d'abord en termes d'attitude
probablement plus réservés - sur le
devant de la scène
et puis avec des contraintes le fait et
bien tout simplement de fonder une
famille une femme
eh bien on ne peut pas faire que sa
carrière politique souvent il ya des
enfants et un conjoint et c'est quand
même différent d'un homme ou madame
souvent restent à la maison s'occupe des
enfants et lui peut faire carrière d'un
jeu concilier comme beaucoup de femmes
le font leur vie familiale leur vie
professionnelle et mon engagement
politique
quelqu'un était venu me contacter pour
les élections municipales
j'ai été élue ce soir là quand j'ai
appris les résultats je me suis rentré
chez moi je me suis assise sur mon lit
et j'ai pleuré parce que je me demandais
comment en tant que maman célibataire
pour le coup j'allais pouvoir assumer ma
tâche de mamo et puis ma fonction d'élu
municipal il ya une culpabilisation qui
est mise sur les épaules des femmes que
je trouve absolument insupportable on
n'a pas besoin de culpabiliser les
femmes parce que ne sont pas au foyer en
permanence parce qu'elles ont elles
aussi une vie où elles s'épanouissent à
côté au contraire j'avais bien en tête
les difficultés que pourraient
rencontrer une femme dans un milieu
particulièrement masculin
la preuve on m'a opposé je ne pourrais
pas réussir en politique parce que
j'étais maire de quatre jeunes enfants
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de combat encore
pour les femmes qui mérite d'être mené
et là en dehors de la vie politique tant
dans la vie économique que social l'
équilibre au sein de la vie familiale
l' équilibre dans la vie professionnelle
l'accès des femmes à certains postes de
responsabilité c'est à nous de vrais de
bataille et puis de prendre notre place
mais a lancé engageons donc si on ne
fait rien il y aura toujours plus
d'hommes que de femmes
il ya par ce volontarisme
particulièrement dans notre famille
politique et particulièrement de la part
de marielle qui a fait que toute une
génération de femmes a eu la chance de
pouvoir s'engager au sein de notre
mouvement
ces relents politiques ça me fait penser
à quoi ça me fait penser au 21 avril
les 44
le droit de vote donnée aux femmes la
place de la femme dans la société est
évidemment quelque chose de très
important il a fallu des lois sur la
parité pour un peu accéléré le mouvement
enfin mon politique pas évident parce
qu'il faut se faire une place et souvent
de la place est déjà prise par des
hommes pendant que nous nous posons la
question sont notre compétence
on se pose toujours la question nous les
femmes mais est ce que je suis capable
d'y aller les hommes ne se pose pas de
question de savoir s'ils sont compétents
ou pas les femmes c'est 50 % de la
population
donc c'est une force formidable beaucoup
de gens se sont interrogés de sur le
fait de légiférer pour faciliter la
parité aujourd'hui je crois que le
résultat montre qu'on a eu raison de
légiférer la loi sur la parité a permis
l'émergence de nouvelles têtes de femme
et je sais qu'à l'époque beaucoup
d'hommes disait il n'y a pas besoin
d'une loi on le voit à toi tu es lui ai
pas besoin d'une loi pour que les femmes
arrivent en politique l'égalité entre
les femmes et des hommes ça commence
dans la famille ça commence par les des
questions moi j'espère que l'éducation
changera un peu pour permettre justement
l'émergence de deux femmes qui ont envie
de s'engager qu'elles viennent apporter
leur talent qu'elle vienne apporter
aussi leur façon quelquefois un peu
apaisées de construire et surtout leur
envie de construire positivement alors
je suis confronté au sexisme tous les
jours des mots sexistes bien évidemment
j'en ai eu comme je pense toutes les
femmes en ont déjà entendu incompétente
invisible inutile et
y'en a un autre monsieur oublier les
commentaires sur la coiffure sur les
habits ce sont des terres donc on
utilise justement quand on veut
disqualifier une femme en politique
j'essaye de le vivre avec distance et
humour incompétente invisible inutile et
après effectivement parfois je peux me
fâcher un peu aussi le transparente
invisible incompétente et inutile
c'est ça voilà ça peut être vexant
ça peut être déstabilisant on peut avoir
des propos effectivement houde et des
mimiques qui montre un mépris
arrêtez les gars ça suffit on est là on
est là on ne pouvait pas vous pouvez pas
nous effacer d'un coup de gomme il faut
faire avec nous il a fallu lutter un
petit peu l'assemblée nationale pour se
faire sa place on a encore énormément de
collègues un peu machiste
ça commence à changer mais on voit qu'il
ya encore un petit peu de travail
et puis je pense que c'est très
important d'amener cette sensibilité
féminine
j'ai envie de dire à toutes les femmes
osez franchir le pas notre société a
besoin de femmes qui s'engagent à
politique il faut pas avoir peur du
combat oui il faut que les femmes
prennent la parole
elles prennent le pouvoir aussi il faut
qu'elle ose la politique pour gagner en
faveur des femmes femmes osez la
politique
oser oser tout vous avez un petit plus
que n'ont pas les hommes
mesdames engagez vous engagez vous pour
trouver le sens engagez vous parce que
vous avez le droit de le faire
ce un site toutes les jeunes filles
toutes les jeunes femmes toutes les
femmes même d'un certain âge à aller en
politique france fais-toi confiance
femmes osez la politique aux désirs et
politique